okay go to the next one the aquaculture
industry we usually talk about fish but
it actually includes anything that you
can grow in the water or in a water
environment but I'm typically going to
talk about fish here and even at that we
have a broad perspective to go through
we I should preface this whole thing by
saying I'm from Wisconsin and I
typically deal with the northern central
tier of states so what I have to do with
managing water and efforts and so forth
is probably going to be quite different
than East Coast West Coast or the
southern states but up in the northern
tier we have access to cold water cool
water warm water fish we can have fish
and plant combinations like aquaponic
situations we have people that just have
plants growing a hydroponics with no
fish if we do an outdoor culture we've
got a lot of variety there the whole
pond may give me you can have net pens
cages floating raceways on tide on side
teen culture we have flow through
systems that are indoor and we have
recirculating aquaculture systems which
are called Ras you know use Ras quite
frequently so I have to repeat it but
that's a system that's indoors that
recycles all the water and never wastes
it to the outdoors and we also get into
saltwater systems like right now we're
starting to get into shrimp so just to
break down what we are growing oh and
then the other thing I wanted to mention
about 90% of the aquaculture in
Wisconsin that we consider aquaculture
is actually baitfish and then there's
the next 9% is growing trout and the
last 9% is all the other species the
last 1% and so I'm just going to go
through what we actually culture for
food fish and that will apply to bait
fish if they're doing culture an intense
culture so forth so we have
non-indigenous cold water species that
were working with Atlantic salmon arctic
char our new
rainbow trout is the standby that's not
an indigenous species but it it seems
like it cuz it's so cosmopolitan then we
get into what we call cool water wall I
saw a guy perch saw a guy is actually a
hybrid walleye Sagar and it looks the
same as a walleye so I'm just going to
put one picture up but those are cool
water fish and then the next slide will
show and both these are indigenous and
then the indigenous fish and this
picture is your bluegill which is pretty
cosmopolitan but if we want to go
indoors to a real warm water species we
start with tilapia which is normal
aquaponics and we have shrimp there's
there's a rule of that I always use in
managing fish culture what we have to
realize is that we're actually doing two
resources one is your biological
organism that we're managing and that's
what we're thinking of managing and then
the other one is the big one is the
water so any successful aquaculture is
really an exercise in wastewater
treatment and as long as you can provide
good water quality your fish or any
other organism you're working with will
be happy and you will have a successful
operation so when we consider the cool
and warm water species in the northern
tier States we can we can raise them but
we're really limited by maybe three to
four months that they at the tops
walleye maybe a little longer if we go
to cold water species while we were
talking about trout and some onit's
we're either using artesian or well
water yeah and obviously they're cold
water so they they're growing season is
quite a bit longer and for indoor
systems
we're generally working with
temperatures that are 65 to 80 degrees
usually on the higher end and that's in
an Ras system the recirculating
aquaculture system and by and some of
these species are definitely warm water
they cannot be grown outdoors the types
of waste that we get we generally will
get a solid waste from the
and that's our pcs and we're it's very
obvious if you raise fish in aquarium
you'll see that but an additional waste
comes from our operations if we're
feeding food which we always go for on
the grow but that food if we over feed
that is an excess solid waste and that
could be more more biological oxygen
that could be more demanding than
defeated then the fish feces itself and
we also have dissolved waste coming from
the fish usually from the gills and
that's on nitrogenous waste ammonia and
that has to be taken care of and then if
we go back indoors to an RAS system we
have to treat both the solid waste and
the dissolved waste typically an RAF
system is self-contained but we as we're
pulling the waste out of it we might
have to make up about 10 percent of the
total volume of the RAS but all these
wastes are oxygen can to consuming
entities and they have to be that that
waste has to be solved so let's go to
the treatment of waste in the outer
systems fort on the treatment is going
to be aeration there's almost nothing
else you can do and if you're in a pond
whether it's a cage or in a pond proper
aeration is going to be mandatory
especially when we get to the warmer
temperatures of July and August and the
farther south you go the more that
becomes a bigger problem sometimes if
you're using floating Raceway static
raceways or on-site tanks the flow is
sufficient to eliminate the need for
oxygenation but it has to be there as a
standby the indoor systems we have some
flow through systems but generally not
most of them are closed-loop systems and
they require a more sophisticated waste
treatment system you know you start with
solids removal and then you have a
second step for the dissolved solid and
gaseous waste which would be basically
converting ammonia to nitrate and that's
a biological process you know
a little bit about the complications of
that later so I put a couple pictures in
for those that I mean I think you know
most of what I've been talking about
except these slides are of what I have
does by pondside teen culture the ones
on the left are the low profile and I
use those for spawning eggs feet
training fry and fingerling size grading
but then the next year when I go I have
the bigger tanks for the grow-out and
basically you're starting with like
these are for perch and if I'm starting
with a four inch perch I'll go to the
grow out in four months so that's that's
the setup for that and notice that
here's the girl tanks and then this is a
this is actually a solid collection tank
so that's one of the things I do so
there's no solids collection here but
there's no solid waste accumulating
there either and this is a little odd
for our part of the country but this is
a shrimp tank set up a lot of them this
is about 80 degrees and this is just a
large full barn and this the one on the
right is a small aquaponics you have the
fish tank a little degassing tanks for
ammonia treatment and then you have
that's converted to nitrates what is
used by the plants and that's a very
small unit being on high school or maybe
your basement
so not nothing real big there's
obviously they're very large systems
when they get into aquaponics okay so
let's talk about the physical parameters
and what are the most important
parameters to look for the one that
drives everything I talked a lot about
oxygen
INRI oxygenation and the one thing about
oxygen is that it's all temperature
related oxygen saturation is the highest
at low temperatures and you lose
saturation the higher the temperatures
are that's why we have so much problem
holding oxygen in July in August then
there we have to put a lot of aeration
in in a system and conversely in the
winter
we don't may not aerate at all the rate
of waste treatment occurs much faster
with warm temperatures again as the
warmer temperatures occur then we get
oxygen eaten up a lot faster because the
waste treatment occurs faster
oxygen consumption by fish and the
wasted justin is significant lowering
cool temperatures which would be winter
which is most of the time up here and
the cool spring and fall is cool so very
little oxygen demand or I should say
extensive oxygen demand in the middle of
summer but not so in the rest of the
time indoor systems generally they're
really warm but sometimes they go with a
cold water fish and it's important to
know this is critical right here the
rate of converting ammonia to nitrate
which is what you have to do an indoor
system will be dependent upon your
biological treatment system very much
reduced in coal temperature so for
working with warm temperatures it works
pretty good but you have to be cognizant
of the fact that it doesn't work if at
all when it's very cold okay for solids
removal typically we're actually I'm
able to remove solids from an outdoor
pond until after a growing season or if
we have to take a pond down there's one
other thing I forgot to add in here a
lot of ponds you can do wheat harvesting
and that's that's a reduction in solids
but there you're you're really doing
that to pull out the nutrients and
actually if you let that overwinter all
those plants are going to decompose in
your pond and actually be a deficit for
oxygen so that's a solid removal where
that comes in some outdoor situations as
I said before you can remove solids as
as are generated like in raceways and
flow channels and specifically in in
ponds I taste which is what I do in
general
we we don't have many permits wastewater
permits typically the federal
requirements prevail they're pretty much
best management practice for the
aquaculture industry however the largest
discharges may be subject to wastewater
discharge permits I think we only have
one or two of them in the state of
Wisconsin so that shows you how
infrequent a permit is everybody's
supposed to be under the best management
practices most states will follow the
federal loo lead with respect to permits
and if you do have a permit it's going
to be based on solids biochemical oxygen
demand an ammonia and now most recently
we're seeing new restrictions on
phosphorous and he's a very low level
but they're based on Basin whole Basin
waste Lord watershed loading and so it
may be a problem at hundred miles away
but it starts at your place so
phosphorous is the new kid on the block
here